David Halberstam is editor of the new
collection defining a nation our America
and the sources of its strength during
this hour 15 minute talk he's joined by
contributors Amy Chua and Roger Wilkins
welcome we have a little intimate
gathering here tonight one of the
greatest jobs that i had was working for
the Today Show at one point doing a
segment called cross country three of us
got to kind of go around America and do
whatever we wanted to about this country
and during a portion of that I drove my
red 63 cadillac convertible around the
United States and tried to stop only at
roadside attractions or places like this
where somebody would have a statue of
the Liberty in the back of a pickup and
I thought I was finding what was to me
the essence I was finding what appealed
to me about this country and it was the
fact that people could be such
individuals whatever their dream was
they could build it they could go to a
part of this country was big enough to
have room to take them all in and let
them pursue that this book and you can
see the list of names of the people who
have written essays in it tell us a lot
about what made that possible it is not
just personal experiences but it is a
great history of the events and things
that happen in this country that led us
be who we are and we are fortunate to
have three of the authors of essays here
including the editor of the book and the
man who sort of came up with the idea
for it so let me quickly bring them up
here we will introduce someone who will
get right to discussing defining a
nation our America and the sources of
its strength David Halberstam if you'll
come up as an addition David Halberstam
is people know as a journalist and
author Pulitzer Prize winners written
numerous books about the Vietnam War II
wrote the powers to be the best the
brightest summer 49 many others ended he
is the editor of this book and the man
who talked others like Roger Wilkins
Roger will come up who is also an author
and professor professor of history in
American culture
George Mason University also a Pulitzer
Prize winner for water day coverage and
Amy Chua professor of law at the Yale
University and also and off everybody
here is writing world of fire how
exploring free-market democracy breeds
ethnic hatred and global instability and
I think what defines Americo if you were
going to do a visual portrait of it you
could just look at the people up here on
this stage and you would get a sample of
at least a taste of the mosaic that is
America but can put a geographic
description on David Halberstam he would
be a Russian polish Ukrainian Lithuanian
Jewish Amy Chua representing the asian
american chinese american and roger
african-american and me a texan which is
a courses guns or sometimes claims to be
an independent nation here you spent a
little time in Texas Austin went to
school in Austin in El Paso as a boy
there you go I guess if I had to train
my own roots a part of me on my mother's
side is very small part is Native
American but as you can see the European
genes have probably taken over
particularly my father's whose
great-grandparents came from Denmark the
immigrant experience is one element
certainly not all that defines this
nation some people were brought here
forcefully against their will some came
escaping something oppression genocide
war some came looking for wealth and
fame before whatever the reasons America
seemed to offer hope for a better life
an opportunity especially for your
children to do better than you it was we
had an inflation of expectations that
each generation was going to do better
this was a place where you can make your
dreams come true let me share one
personal note about how close my own
dreams can come true as you know in this
country believe any person can grow up
to be President or any natch any natural
born citizen he native-born American of
course now anybody in this country can
grow up to be governor of California
but in my own experience this is how
close history came to being altered if I
can just share this with you because and
you can see all of our lives might be
different because I too grew up in
Midland Texas I true once lived on west
ohio street you know went to Sam Houston
Elementary I to kind of screwed off in
school and did not do it and I kind of
screwed off after school afterwards I
too had to be wait until my 40s until my
wife could straighten me out and put me
on the straight and narrow my father too
once worked in the oil fields and I to
work in the oil fields of Midland Texas
so as you see I could be your president
of the United States good and over new
okay well there was one little twist in
mind my daddy's name was George Matson
not George Bush but that's how closely
what makes this country unique haven
well I think that's when the sourcing is
not any one thing it's the source of
what we were trying to find the sources
of energy I mean a blessed piece of land
rich a great climate a diversity of
population a wonderful constitutional
background which we got from our British
forefathers which we occasionally pay
attention to but gives us a balance of
laws a constant source of energy from
from New Americans coming here and
believing that in one generation their
children can do more and have more
opportunity than they had in the old
country um an odd innocence a sense that
lie that I mean it's one of the things
that's both a strength and a weakness
belief that life is somehow perfectible
and that you can be better oddly a sort
of a disrespect that goes along with it
for history we don't feel that history
is a burden that we can you know history
is something we don't have to pay
we're Americans we can make history we
can make the future um I I think we're
really very lucky and very blessed and
when Lee I mean I've worked in so many
other parts of the world as a young
reporter in whatever our flaws and I
think any good reporter has a constant
argument with his or her own country as
to why it isn't better why we you know
the relics and the pain of overcoming
those years of slavery all these things
up you still believe that this country
can be made better that it is a better
place to live and that the society is
still open so let me use that as just a
kind of opening remark that was what we
were trying to get at with this book
when my wife and I looked for the
sources of strength and and getting a
wonderful assemblage of writers who
would be willing to write about Rogers
cases Brown Amy the writing about the
new American immigration Martino and my
colleague writing about the highway bill
other people writing about a land grant
colleges someone else dick Reeves
wonderful colleague writing about the GI
Bill I mean one of the great bargains
this country has ever had in its life
and be one talk about energy and
muscularity and opening up a meritocracy
that's that's a great moment you
mentioned slavery in our and it is a
theme that appears in many of these
essays is the fact that America has had
this battle with races of whether it is
against african-americans her asian
americans people have had to deal with
this and one of the strengths is is that
the country has tried to deal with it
did you think the american dream was is
available to you Roger growing up as you
thought it would be to your white
friends well in beginning I didn't have
any white friends because I lived in
segregation in kansas city missouri and
my first recorded response to the
society I saw we lived a small
segregated community inside kansas city
and the boundary of our community was
twenty sixth street when I was little my
mother and my grandmother to call me
Roger so I thought my name was Roger
baby and they say that and to get to
that 26b we had to go through two blocks
of segregation the black people and
apparently when I was very young I said
asked why is it that up to twenty sixth
Street everybody smiles and says hello
Roger baby and then after 26 feet
everybody is mean I didn't say they were
white but they were I didn't and figured
that out but so but when I began to
understand what the country was about
time I was four and five I knew that my
parents and their friends all of them
educated people were leading very
constricted lives I knew that I heard
them talk about and my moments with my
father were precious big our precious to
me even now because he died before I was
nine and one of the things that we would
do on Sunday nights he would often walk
with me to viaduct over a railroad track
and we would look at the new streamlined
train they would go by I just love that
train
and I told him that I that's what I
wanted to do when I grew up to try a
train and I guess at that moment he
decided what now was the time to give
the kid the truth and so he said well
you won't be able to do that and so why
not and he said only white people can
drive trains and I said but that's not
fair and he said that's right he said
but they make the rules I said was not
fair and he said well you were supposed
to fight against that all your life so I
didn't think that I was able to grow up
and be what white people could be but I
knew that I was supposed to fight it all
my life and I'm 71 and that's what I've
tried to do was there a point at which
you thought we have now gotten to the
point where anything is possible no void
because I was um by the time the civil
rights movement had come to its fruition
I was one of very fortunate people I
afraid he'd like people born in nineteen
thirty to the depths of depression who
had not one but two college educated
parents and I went to college and so by
the end of the 60s or the mid sixties
when all kinds of American institutions
were looking around frantically for a
way to integrate the place there weren't
that many people who had the credentials
to do that so in rapid succession I
integrated the top levels of the Justice
Department's the Ford Foundation the
Washington Post in the New York Times
and I knew the whole world wasn't going
to be open because I could see the kind
of resistance that a fortunate black
person like me got in trying to help
reshape the institution and it was even
worse when I tried to get the
institution to focus on the plight of
the black poor who had been left behind
so now I had I had no illusions none I
think what's one of the interesting
things pointed out of this in the book
and that you talked about in the
beginning david is the fact that it was
the last two thirds of the 20th century
that America became much of what it is
and we tend to think well here was the
Constitution here with the Bill of
Rights they were right there from the
beginning giving this sense of equality
that all men are created equal but it
did not come into being even though
whatever the word said on these pieces
of paper it was not until the 20th
century when the courts began to enter V
and it began to change so even though
the words were there the promise was
there the reality was not well I think I
mean a country has its own meter and its
own levels of progression and a number
of things advanced that I mean that had
been building in the courts the
philosophy of World War two fighting for
democracy against totalitarian fo head I
think had been a an egalitarian moment
and I think it had a level it drove a
level of change and the coming of the
civil rights movement married up as it
was with the television evening news a
Martin King is a great teleplay right of
orchestrating events that lured the
Beast of segregation to the surface so
that order Americans could sit in their
home and his wonderful new thing then
rather better done than
is now evening nightly news up and see
the price of racism in the south to know
to see the things that were always below
the surface King did that brilliantly we
did in an inverted and interesting ten
years time Brown versus Board of
Education is 54 Emmett Till is killed in
July 55 an army of northern journalists
collects in in Tallahatchie County
Mississippi in December of 55 Martin
Luther King starts the Montgomery bus
boycott in 10 years ending with the
voting rights act of 65 the country has
this enormous surge but televisions key
component in which it it gets rid of
legal and political state-sanctioned
races and this is a huge breakthrough
but it does not break all the other
dynamics of racism educational economic
psychological all the the vast burdens
that we did not know were there in which
we had inflicted on some of our citizens
over 200 years but there is that
enormous progress which is both surface
progress and some of it real but it does
not affect everybody in the society hey
Amy your parents were sitting at another
country looking at America where Chinese
had not always been welcome here and in
World War two Japanese were being locked
up and yet your father the way you write
instantly love this country and thought
this was the promised land yeah my
family definitely falls into the
category of the new Americans who really
benefited from the changes in the second
two thirds of them the 20th century my
parents were ethnic Chinese and they
were born in the Philippines and they
lived through Japanese occupation in the
Philippines which is a horrible time for
them and my father still remembers being
liberated by american troops i mean this
is
a vision that is you know everybody my
family can imagine MacArthur driving
down and a very skalian image that I
record us he remembers US troops tossing
out free cans of spam and might and you
know them gathering up and even when I
was in the United States as a little
girl growing up my father would buy spam
and fry it up and it was and there's but
they my father hated the Philippines it
was just he was a it was a brilliant
math math you left philosophy he loved
astronomy but he was in a business
family and they were supposed to work in
the family can business and they didn't
like his choice of a wife she was from
an intellectual poor family so my
parents actually eloped from the
Philippines of all places believe it or
not they eloped to MIT Massachusetts but
it was a dream come true he my father
wrote an application and he got this you
know airmail letter six months later
accepting him on a partial scholarship
so my mother and my father in 1960
packed up they had two suitcases a
mother barely spoke any English and they
just arrived like so many other
immigrants that's so striking to read
this book the I don't know if I would
have the courage but to arrive in a
country where you know no one you know
no one and the first few years were very
difficult and this is just almost like a
cliche of a rags-to-riches dream they my
parents didn't have any money when they
came over because my father was
essentially just owned when he left and
during the very cold Boston winters they
actually couldn't afford heat the first
few years so they my parents said that
they just wore blankets around to keep
warm or you know and but but fast
forwarding I mean things my father
worked crazily hard i think it's mrs.
affected me and and but my i have three
younger sisters and for us growing up we
don't really think about the American
dream I'm it was really i my my
experience was very very different from
yours but I also I felt like an outsider
not an unhappy outsider
but I was definitely different from
everybody else and and it was very stark
we had to bring chinese food and
thermoses to to school and everybody
else had sandwiches and and at home week
we were not allowed to sleep over
anybody's houses and every day we had to
come home from school we drilled math
and piano all afternoon and in my family
this is a little bit i do synchronic but
we were required to speak chinese at
home my parents really wanted to keep
that so for every English word
accidentally uttered when I was little
we received one whack of the chopsticks
so as a very and I took my father's
shoes off every day and but I and you
know we were it was he was very very
strict I tell the story of I once
received second place in a history
contest when I was in eighth grade and I
brought my parents to the award ceremony
and somebody else had won the prize for
best all-around student and after the
award ceremony where everybody else was
getting taken out to ice cream my father
took me aside and said never never
disgraced me like that again so and I
you know when that sticks of you but I
explain how you call your father
happened in Jewish homes explain how you
call your father quintessential American
and yet he was requiring the Chinese and
Chinese food but he also introduced you
you said two sloppy joes yes I mean I I
just was a dichotomy it was a almost as
schizophrenic die economy but I my main
thing is I think America changes people
or maybe not everybody but America
definitely changed my family it changed
us and so my father while he was trying
to maintain the sense of who he was this
Chinese patriarch side he was at the
same time all excited he did introduce
us I he was just you know touch I
remember dairy queens and eat all you
can buffets or a great discovery of and
sloppy joes and tacos and then we went
crabbing and sledding and I mean it was
really a land of unlimited opportunity
it really felt like that and we looked
weird I know that my sisters and I and
my family we looked weird everybody
stared at us but in retrospect at least
it feels like we had a great time
and my father also changed over time and
I think he wouldn't admit it to himself
you know when we were little he was
completely not interested in politics
but then by the time I so when I was in
fourth grade he moved to Berkeley and he
grew his hair long and he was wearing
had peace signs all over him and now you
know quotes the Constitution and they're
there and he was never like that and and
another feature is Asian societies are
often very prejudiced against
handicapped people there's just a
terrible tradition in in Asia you know
so when my youngest sister was born with
Down syndrome the my relatives the
Philippines who had just newly
reestablished relations because they
needed green cards but they but they
wrote and said look we could take your
sister Yun this baby with Down syndrome
pickup sent her back to the Philippines
and nobody will ever know and my mother
and I credit America it sounds you know
idealistic but she somehow that wasn't
no longer possible I think she would
have done that maybe you know in another
context but she Scott all these books
joined all these organizations and my
sister you know is 12 special olympics
gold medals and volunteers at a hospital
so I say my father's the quintessential
American because I I think he represents
all the changes that the most the best
kinds of changes that America can
produce in people one of the changes
that early immigrants often did was to
change their name from a european
spelling this is a wonderful story that
david has put in the introduction to the
book it's it's my mother's side of the
family and was told to me once when I
was a young man by my uncle but my my
mother's side came from Vilnius Vilna
and they were in family discussions they
were the the lit fox and my maternal
grandfather had made it to West
Tennessee where he did not do terribly
well apparently in business his name was
solinger and being told that his name
was too Jewish he thereupon changed it
to levy
happy that take every once in a while
when I I need to be brought down I like
to think of that story um there's an inn
formality listening to you i was
thinking of the in formality of American
culture compared to the old world of in
the old world was very hierarchical
fathers were always right and to be
obeyed wives were silent children had to
be and in the informality of America
which really I think runs through it now
starts in California works as well East
it works its way eastward fewer and
fewer ties are spotted the clothes
become more comfortable and more driven
by whether you can watch in so many
occasions this in formality of this
culture take place and change and it is
driven by the children and now it's
driven on television screens to the rest
of the world which where it is in fact a
very attractive culture because it is
less stiff and unbending and it is
driven a bit more by what you are rather
than title which i think is an American
gift to the world do you think from what
you said about informality in California
coming back that this means that we're
going to have Arnold without a tie
t-shirt god I love the fact that Ariana
has dropped out I think Arnold's done
worked better on his pronunciation and
Ariana hasn't Ariana had just written a
book I really love this is he really let
the California gubernatorial races the
last refuge of sorrow that she'd written
a book called pigs at the trough that it
turns out that she has not paid income
tax for two years although she said more
than I heard a lot of he's made a lot of
money in property tax because he has
these multi-million dollar oh well
remembering who we are
those who came as immigrants and all of
us have connection to some ethnic past
and yet we define this country of us
blending together into the melting pot
and becoming America's are how important
is it to hold on to a bit of who we are
and where we came from lunch well I
think we do both and listening to a me
particularly you can hear how hanging on
to both has enriched her and her family
and her parents and oddly i would say
that that is true for a lot of black
people as well in my parents generation
and earlier blacks were made to feel
ashamed of slavery because the culture
said to you black people were slaves
because they deserve to be slaves
because they were inferior and were able
to do no better thinking than picking
cotton and it was so bad i mean here's
my mother a Phi Beta Kappa from the
University of Minnesota a woman who had
a very powerful middle class career
ended up his president of first black
national president of the white ebc the
United States and a kind of the driving
power of the Episcopal Diocese of
Western Michigan as a layperson but when
I asked her when I was about 40 some
questions about our family back in the
past she told me some things and I
looked at her and I said why did you
tell me that stuff when we were when I
was growing up and she said she looked
very pensive and very sad and she said
well Roger in our family I guess we
didn't like to clank our chains
a very powerful but by the time it got
to my generation we had we were
participants in the civil rights
movement and we began to reconsider the
definitions of us that had been imposed
upon us by the more powerful culture and
by this time the old system was breaking
up so you could see although I couldn't
see that I could be present in the
United States you could see all kinds of
possibilities that hadn't been there in
your childhood and so you began to
reconsider slavery and i remember it was
like an epiphany I said one day we'll
hell I'm not the one who's supposed to
be ashamed of slavery no and then you
began to let your slave ancestors in and
the more you let them in the more you
love them because of what they had to
endure and you knew that you couldn't be
here if they hadn't mean a lot of people
committed suicide it was hellacious if
they didn't and my great-grandparents
who were didn't have it easy they were
Mississippi field slave so was my
grandma my great-grandfather my
great-great grandparents and they had a
religious faith that said it's going to
be better someday we'll be free and I
just love those people so and they give
me strength they give me enormous
strength but now to the whole hour just
I recently wrote a book about black
patriotism and about the founding of the
country and some place in it I said one
of the reasons I chose for Virginians
Washington Mason and Jefferson was
because I wanted to look at Virginia
because I was curious about the fact
that I had a great grandfather who was
born free
and in about the 1880s in Virginia how
could he have been free and I was
curious about that well well it was a
genealogist in the northern neck of
Virginia in the area from which my
great-grandfather came started doing
research fee and if you're black the
only thing you really know about the
Daughters of the American Revolution is
that they wouldn't let Marian Anderson
sing it constitution hall you know and
so this woman did some research and she
found out a lot about my family and I
went down there one time and she showed
me a lot of things a lot of places where
they had been and so forth and she said
but I've got more things to find out for
you and one day she called me and she
said Roger I have wonderful news for you
and I will say well what's that Caroline
she said you are eligible for membership
in the Sons of the American Revolution
because she had found out that one of my
mother's distant relatives had sir line
up to enlistments in the Revolutionary
War so in all of its weird and wondrous
ways the country does do things but I
would elaborate dystrophy you give me
two more sense you know when you ask
David about the Constitution and the
Declaration of Independence the original
Constitution strengthened slavery it did
not weaken it but the Declaration of
Independence the preamble was this
wonderful stuff bought uh we hold these
truths to be self-evident so forth
became kind of a touchstone for
Americans even though it had no legal
significance and for black people that
was kind of a beacon you know even in
slavery that was kind of vegan and then
of course Lincoln
kind of wrote that into the founding at
Gettysburg and then those essence those
promises were written into the
Constitution after the Civil War but I
think really that and essentially Old
Testament religion was what gave lots of
enslaved black people the stay the
strength to exist in indore slavery and
also the idea that they wanted to be
free Americans in America they didn't
want to go to Africa they want to be
here and it's a remarkable story Rogers
really too modest his book Jefferson's
pillow is a is a brilliant book it's one
of the very best books done last year's
a rumination on race and patriotism and
one of the most extraordinary story in
America is the degree of loyalty and
patriotism under appalling conditions
and the the in fact nobility of American
box in being loyal to a country before
long before it really deserves their
their loyalty and I mean the man for
whom the FBI building his name never
understood this of course um I mean he
believed because of that they would be
vulnerable to communism but in fact the
tiny incidents of blacks being in the
Communist Party there's alienation pain
but it was never disloyalty it was
always a fierce loyalty and it fears
Patriot which is one of the most
stunning things about the black story in
the country and Roger really writes
brilliantly about this of course what
the people in this book right about that
make that define this nation is is also
more than the racial makeup and if we
could just quickly touch on some of
those things one of this is just a huge
country with vast open space is still
right there were 76 million people
around the 1900s and 276 million today
but we still got all of this room out
west some states are we don't have much
room on the Beltway pal not on the 495
but so I to me it was like we were also
defined by the fact that they were just
room to be who you wanted to did you get
that you could go you didn't have to
stay in New York or Connecticut or Yale
no it's it's so market it definitely the
feeling was you could go anywhere it was
a huge country you could go anywhere and
actually Asia is a great comparison a
peep there's just there is no room I
mean there's no space at all everybody
is crowded together so so this kind of
feeling of frontiers and it was almost a
perfect metaphor my father started off
on East Kosan at some point he decided
that he was going to pack up and go west
you know and so we did and looking for
better things but it's interesting i
think this related to the earlier point
I there was a puzzle to me about the
United States I could not agree more
than I think clinging retaining
something of who you are and where you
came from is has got to be a source of
strength but I think it's something it's
not always the case I mean my other work
I focus on other countries and in
Southeast Asia for example the Chinese
cling to their identities their Chinese
and the result is that there they are
viewed as Outsiders they feel they're
outsiders and they don't think of
themselves as Indonesians or Filipinos
and this is part of the friction but in
this country I think it's there's you
could cling you can be who you are with
all the stains and the terrible problems
and yet there is this you know you
mentioned loyalty and patriotism I mean
this is over Archie feeling of but I'm
an American and it's consistent it can
be consistent so I thought that was I
don't know a puzzle I don't know why
it's not true everywhere you know well
you know there was this amazing thing in
World War two we're japanese americans
were interned oh yeah and yet there were
brigades of japanese
American soldiers fighting ferocious
long legendary legendary heroism right
so that the country has this amazing
poll and you know fact it was one it was
one early way that immigrants one there
Americanism they could not Irish in the
Civil War assigning up and taking the
place of people of Los p or backgrounds
my father couldn't wait to volunteer for
world war one and my grandfather who was
born in the old country was so proud
that he had two sons in Europe and it
was a way and if you look at our
monuments war by war i mean it is not
the children of the upper middle class
who are whose names are on that
extraordinary monument a few blocks from
here that those are as ever Nemanja and
in fact even now in Iraq there are many
Americans of Hispanic background who are
in the army because it is a shortcut to
a green card I mean this country it is
one of those ways of getting your
identity and I think America's very can
be very good at having a kind of dual
emotional identity you can be an
American and I think that's all in my
generation that was very important
assimilation post-world war two being an
American but you can also be part of
that which existed in the old country
and it and in your family there is this
sense we always had taught to us by our
parents and grandparents that you gave
back if you were lucky enough to do well
you if you went to a good school that
was not to be used for sheer material
exploitation but to be a good citizen to
give back and we have really in our
family in on my generation we've tried
to pass that on to our our daughter I
mean I think there's a duality and I
think that's a source of strength in
this country that you can have these two
identities David should they was very
modest about his daughter she is in her
second year as a Teach for America
teacher in Greenville Mississippi
teaching so in some very tough school
when you talk about the military that
had a defining chapter in this book and
you mentioned this earlier is the GI
Bill which we didn't go into in depth
which did more for moving people out of
where they were moving up to different
parts of the country and taking them to
a different station in life education
wise and getting them perhaps out of the
traditional family business because for
the first time they come back from the
war and they're given some money to go
to school and money to buy housing which
is part of the American dream to own
your own home and all of this was
possible I was surprised to learn myself
not because of our idea that we want to
do something good for the soldiers but
we were worried what we're going to do
with all this influx of people with the
high unemployment already and suddenly
here are people ready to go into the job
market and have no job so we decide
we'll send them to school there's a
great sense that a movie oh it's really
worth watching it's very good historical
piece the best years of our lives Dana
Andrews and the young guy who really had
lost both hands in in in in in World War
two but it's about that moment of coming
back it's about the coming of a
meritocracy because it's very easy to
forget in this America with its great
new social fluidity at a new wonderful
meritocracy that there had been a law
cam there before that before World War
two the people went to college were the
children of the people who been to
college and not that many people were
getting across the the moat to get there
and then world war two I think gave a
whole generation of Americans a
confidence of what they could be doing
instead of being druggists assistance in
the local pharmacy they were leading
platoons or you know commanding or doing
important work on a destroyer and they
got it they saw the rest of the world
ested whack soldiers very important they
saw what they could be they saw that the
people who came from seemingly more
noble blood weren't really more noble
and there was an emotional and
psychological explosion which was fed by
this great investment the country made
in its
in the GI Bill and that is in terms of
the democratization of America and I
think as much psychological and
emotional as educational that's a great
turning point that's unleashing I mean I
think this book is what I want to do in
this book was find out you know the
unleashing of our energies why do why do
we have this high energy level why do we
sort of i think gets so much talent out
of ordinary people the nobility of
ordinary people and i was looking for
that and I think the GI Bill is a
critical moment and once that's done we
the egalitarian spirit and the land
grant colleges take over we are in
danger of losing that we are in danger
because of the cost of education of now
just in the old days it was education
was restricted based on class and it'll
lead at the top got it and now we are in
danger of having self-perpetuating
because the people who have access to it
are already in the upper middle class
and the price even at a state university
is becoming really sorbitol and so
that's a real dilemma for us Amy do you
remember your first car my first car I
it certainly didn't come from my parents
I was not allowed to what did the car
mean to you was that is I have a
sixteen-year-old daughter who just said
to me she's getting her license in four
days if I'm a little nervous tonight but
she says I can hardly wait because then
i will be free to her at reverence it
means she has a new independence my
freedom came later they didn't give me
that because that was another i remember
all my friends could drive and had cars
but that was another thing i couldn't do
just like i couldn't have sleepovers so
i think i didn't get my first car till
lost that was your first true
Americanization moment where you sort of
got away from the rules rather stricter
rules of your home no sleeper when did
you have a feeling of being really doing
something that would have been
forgetting forbidden in the home but was
a very American thing too
well you know I always never quite
believed my father I mean he would say
these things but I knew that the big
story was that he was the rebel he left
so he's trying to was trying to teach us
deference to Authority your father but I
we always knew that he left his family
he walked away never came back so I
everything he said had a double edge to
it you know and and there were a lot of
defining moments I mean there was a lot
of hiding and it's not all Pleasant I
hit a lot of things to my parents
because they were too strict they would
have no idea what I was doing you know
that would be stunned if they knew but
but I told us there were nothing it was
you know like you know by ice cream that
was but one moment um uh all defining
its I I did a lot of things I you know I
wanted Daughters of the American
Revolution poetry contest and but but
one moment that I don't know if this is
quite the moment you're looking for
David I am I my father are taking us all
over the world we were doing because he
became very successful and I was you
know we spent time in Munich and lows an
and went to the Arctic Circle but when I
was 17 I want to apply to colleges and
there was a part of my father that was
very free it was you know he was like
other Americans so I started to get
college applications i was going to
apply and my father announced no no you
don't need to do that because you're
staying home you're going to berkeley
where i teach you'll live at home you'll
know car you know and annual and that's
that and i disobeyed my father and i
think this is something to do with the
if we I don't know if it's in formality
or you might not do that in the old oh
never but somehow I believe he condoned
it because of what I did is I i applied
to only one school a school I'd heard
about on the East Coast it was called
Harvard I knew nothing about it and I
forged my father's signature and I send
it off American
but when I was accepted to this one
school my father was incredibly happy
about it he could immediately changed
his mind so I was I always I was right
to not believe him I mean he he wanted
me to break the barriers but he kind of
had was of two minds about it so so that
was a very pivotal moment for me I don't
know just because I I didn't know what
he was gonna do you know what I would
have to do it's very American as a whole
generation of Americans who forged their
parents signature in order to get into
the Marine Corps 16 years ago 17 I do
you know that Oh y'all doing it on
report cards well I keep coming back the
automobile because i think the
automobile in the highway system in this
country which is extraordinary if you've
traveled in other countries and tried to
get around on the roads there and also
in a lot of other countries it's very
limited the population is not allowed to
move freely but here you could get in
the car and you could drive across
country in the summer you were kids on
the east coast you would drive to Fort
Lauderdale during spring break in
college if you were in Michigan tried to
get out you know it was it was the car
capital of the world and so you could
get your driver's license in Michigan
where I lived when I was a teenager at
14 not your learner's permit the whole
Monte you know and of course that was
the rite of passage and you would taught
by your parents and then you would go to
the place where they taught you I mean
where they tested you and you would go
with a friend who had turned 14 two
months earlier not because he had to be
with somebody had a license you passed
the test and you immediately went out to
what was then called the east beltline
which was a road outside the city we can
have interstates then and I was 14 and
1946 so we're still driving pre-war cars
by and large and ours was a hudson
terraplane 1937 hudson terraplane and
you would go out on this road with your
buddy maybe it picked up some other
buddies on your car full of guys and
you'd go out there and you didn't put a
diet that was the rite of passage effort
I did I look at my high school friends
whom I don't see very often now but I'm
really amazed that was still alive
there's so many reasons to say that when
you look back at your youth the idea
that this country needed an interstate
highway systems was under the Eisenhower
administration that it really came to
fruition and what's interesting is a
young man coming out of though his world
war one he'd been part of the survey
team to go across the country and survey
the state of the roads in this country
and it took them forever did he he had
dreamed about it starting back when he'd
done the mapping of it and it was
probably the most powerful lobby ever
put together in this country for any one
purpose because you had the Automobile
Manufacturers the tire manufacturers you
had the great construction companies you
had the labor movement I mean it steel
rubber I mean everybody was in on I mean
don't get in the way of it and it really
worked me to change the country and we
probably diminished public
transportation we didn't reinvest in
certain cities and public transportation
the way that we should have and on the
other hand with this enormous land mass
which so differentiates us from Europe
and where everything's closed in and we
are expansive um it gave us a network
and it gave us access to each other and
it diminished loneliness I'm sure it was
hard
on all kinds of small towns which began
to dry up and it gave us a culture of
cars banking I mean we've got a great
piece in your bill geist on living in
your cars wonderful writer with CBS now
used to be with the New York Times is
about Americans and their cars eating in
them driving in the banking and the
drinking and no I mean living them i
mean it is the sign of not just
independence when you're young but oddly
enough in our culture individualism and
we are that is part of our culture that
is our cocoon where we can shut out the
rest of the world you could go and be
alone in your car and people think
they're alone do they do this may i have
a long commute i commute from here to
fairfax i am telling you you look at the
next car god knows what you're going to
see people doing it well for a while I
lived in my car so I've used the car for
a lot of purposes there are other
countries that are large ever have lots
of natural resources they have not
seemed to do is what natural researchers
where the key russia would be the
richest country in the world and yet it
is so what almost a hundred ago we have
if we have set this example that we keep
talking about how people want to come
here from all over the world they hold
this up as the ideal of what they can be
like at this more you why is not this
duplicated in every other i really have
to start in back of being a first of all
it's fairly temperate climate that's
know that break already lucky and in
fertile ground right but secondly it was
this frame of mind that people came here
with here's this vast if this first of
all is this just a little tiny strip of
thirteen colonies on the eastern
seaboard but i just spoke down it to
montpelier on sunday james madison's
home you sit on the front porch there
and you look out over the blue ridge and
you can just imagine the fastness and it
was true of all these Virginians they
SAT there and they imagined the vastness
and for them the words West and future
merged you take that with the words and
the spirit of the Enlightenment which
were written into our founding document
that says it's that essentially you can
go out and be whatever you want to be
and you can leave the crowded European
past behind the the corruption of Europe
and go out and be in Jefferson's idea
the yeoman farmer West's future West's
you take all those things together and
are just great luck and having this vast
rich unexplored continent so the
people's dreams did in fact come true
and an enormous amount of commercial
empire I mean people were rewarded for
going out and moving and then they were
reported in the caf the balance
capitalist system which had forces
mitigating it against it at critical
times but there was always commercial
reward for doing these things we have
now explored the border to border is
that dream still true still available is
it still the land of promise I I think
for many I mean it's one thing that you
really see from the essays is that
America so many different there's so
many different America's it matters so
much when you come what group you were
belong to and when in within that group
you came I mean my own story is totally
different from the group of asian
americans that came over to work on the
railroads in the 19th century that's
totally different trajectory and much
much less upward mobility and even to
this day when I go to Chinatown and I
can pretty much place Chinese people I
know when I can tell exactly when their
ancestors came over which generation
they are
just by the way they dress and where
they are in life and where they live so
but to answer your question I think for
many people yes it still is but we do
face a lot of challenges even within the
Asian American community there are you
know these huge sweatshops in LA and get
new york where people are just working
in the basement it's almost like a
third-world reproduced so so it's
certainly not a land of opportunity for
everybody but there are a lot of people
who still believe it is look at all the
Mexican and American you know then in
here around here you can just see
opposed to 25 years ago the numbers of
Hispanics who were here and working now
you don't know how many have green cards
how many don't but obviously these
people are drawn here because they see
opportunities you see Africans here in
much larger numbers then we used to see
it and if you believe the television
crime shows it's a land of opportunities
for Russian monsters I'm the gravity to
pull the Magnetic Pole of this country
in an age of television which goes over
the world throughout the world is
probably stronger than ever I mean we
send out some show and it gets
television sitcom or whatever and when
it gets viewed in a foreign country or
third world whatever people don't
necessarily are not watching the the
front of the camera by play between the
two goofy teenagers and the boyfriend
they're watching the way they live the
houses the cars the streets the style of
life that when I was a correspondent in
Eastern Europe in the mid-60s the
America the poles would occasionally
allow certain movies to be shown because
they reflect they thought they reflected
badly on capitalism well the polls were
paying attention to the screenplay they
were looking at the back
of the movie and seeing all those cars
and how well people were dressed and
that is a great great seductive thing
and the in formality I believe that one
of the things that is that they really
don't like in the Islamic world is the
our exportation of our sitcom prime
shows where women cops are arresting and
all the time I mean flipping them on
their back and cuffing them and whatever
I mean the pull of this is in many ways
more powerful than ever and people see
that part of us that energy that we've
been talking here the good life the
better life that we're that we've been
groping at trying to define for you
tonight and they understand it
viscerally and they understand that they
can sort of that they may not get it in
their generation but their children have
a very good sound chance of getting it
and that's a great promise we have just
a few minutes I would like that if we
can take some questions from the
audience you can see if you have any of
you have any questions you like ask the
panel yeah question if the alternate
cover for the book would have been a
dollar bill because when I go to
Europe it's it's it's surprising but
pleasant to see on sunday stores closed
families walking around enjoying
themselves but here it's almost common
to not even worried and stores closed on
Sundays in fact I just thought banks
starting to open up on Sundays
themselves but it's just interesting I
think every generation since you've
moved here may have lost a little bit of
the old ways and kind of like that
accommodating to the new I don't know
whether that let me just repeat was
because of the drive to get that dollar
yeah in case you didn't hear the
question in the backe he was wondering
if the cover the book should have been a
dollar bill since we seem to be a
country driven by the Commerce and the
desire to make money and referring to
the fact in Europe many of the stores
closed on Sunday and now we're looking
at banks opening seven days it's funny
in my in my case this is only a partial
answer my father there was his drive and
it's about freedom and it's about
success but it was exactly the opposite
of money because my father's family was
very wealthy and there was that kind of
money for him but he really wanted
freedom to think and to write he became
a you know middle class professor
actually so it's a very interesting
point you raised but I don't think it's
I don't think it everybody I think
there's enough room that's on
everybody's just going to be a
billionaire maybe i would agree i mean i
think the commercial impulse is
certainly there and everybody i think
people in this country work very hard at
all levels i but i think the impulse is
much more about individualism and about
accomplishment about freedom about being
independent from a boss as it is about
pure materialism I I you know I mean we
are a reflection of the way we've grown
up in our own how
and who are our friends but that's my
reflection that it that pure
commercialism and instinct to maximize
dollars just is not i think it's i think
a better life humor in texas and we had
laws that stores could be open but they
couldn't sell certain i'm so you go down
whole aisles that were closed off on a
sunday they couldn't sell that i am
certain emergency items medical supplies
you could buy so i think some of this is
driven by we just wanted to convenience
i think i'm a little closer to your
point of view than my two colleagues
here in part i suppose because the last
time i talked to my wife was about oh
five hours ago and she was in Neiman
Marcus but I do I must say that the wave
of corporate scandals that we've had
which allowed us to think about how much
corporate CEOs get paid and the kinds of
things that people did with these vast
sums of money there is something that I
think intoxicates and I think
intoxication is a good word for it
people when they be either get on this
road where somehow in the end money
doesn't fully fill them up I know man
worked with him on a committee for the
future of a university yeah you know
what can be a more high-minded thing
than to work on the future of university
and and he was the chairman of the
committee and he was very good he was
very thoughtful he worked very hard he
was very intelligent
he kept us moving and I thought what a
wonderful high-minded public-spirited
citizen that man his name is Ken Lay and
so there was this person that I would
see at these meetings and then there's a
guy who bought not one two or three he
bought four houses in Aspen I mean what
so I and you know this guy cuz Laos ki
who's on trial now what I mean
interesting enough but you know it was
it's a it's a peculiar kind of greed
because I mean koslowski to the
blue-collar guy who sort of makes it
he's making two million three million
and then when he doesn't even really
need the money he goes off on this odd
binge and it becomes more about the ball
score ego your batting average I mean
it's not even I mean it's it's like a
special virus of the CEO as how other
CEOs are going to perceive them and
brings you know got the most RBIs and
the highest batting average I mean it
really isn't about the most elemental
impulses of the society it's an odd
disease and then cuts off ski once he
doesn't need the money he goes on this
crazy binge right any other question yes
sir and members have been talking about
your personal lives here you know you
have gone to admission Airy process on
personal level from your grandparents
and parents in yourself and same way you
know United States had has been going to
illustrator as a nation coming to a
pleasant point where there's no other
superpower we are the only superpower on
planet now so I would like to know how
should we define our self as a nation
one way we are defining ourselves
collectively all the individuals who are
there within this nation defining it as
a nation and on the other hand the rest
of the world is defining us as a nation
and this is there's a dilemma there how
the world sees us my interest is to know
from all of you is how should we define
our services of a role who are as a
nation aiming well that's a it's
actually a question I'm thinking a lot
about myself and struggling with I have
a lot of concerns maybe all the only
thing I'll say is something not so
optimistic sigh me something that
bothers me when I was growing up I was
so proud to be an American everywhere I
went with my father took me to Europe
and you know people always thought it
was weird they thought we were from
China or something but but we were from
America and I was always proud but i
think that the that the America that
that I'm leaving to my children my ten
year older my seven-year-old it's just
not the same I mean no we travel around
and and that is you know mean it's it's
not though it's not the same impression
people don't have the same you you can
you should you try to be proud of your
country but you have to defend it and
you have to explain a lot and so I'm
very struck by the fact that they're
seeing something totally different you
know and I I i don't know i think we
from I think we have changed I think
that there really was a great moment of
American idealism at the end of World
War two when we understood the dangers
that world wars 1 and 2 had posed to the
world and and we knew now that we were
in the world that our oceans
didn't give us immunity so we really
worked very hard to build an
international security and international
financial structure that would stabilize
the world you know we weren't always
right and wise but by and large the
impulse was I think both wise and
generous but it was a time when we were
very confident and felt very good about
ourselves david chronicles a war shortly
after that and it was a war where i was
serving in the administration of our
government it was democratic
administration and it was a different
side of us it was it was more bellicose
more reliant on power than on wisdom and
well we didn't like what we saw and I
think today we have evolved even more
and part of it is this unipolar business
and we see now an exaggeration of the
hubris that we that got us into such
trouble in Vietnam um and I think we are
about to have if our democracy works as
an auto work the 2004 election
really should be a massive debate about
answering your question who are we and
how do we want to be in the world and
how do we want to be perceived in the
world I think we're going to we're
certainly going through a transition and
I don't know quite how to answer that
question right now except that like a me
my pair of my american passport when i
show it but i get off airplanes now
doesn't bring the same smiles that it
did some years ago when I think your
question is a very good one and it is
obviously disturbing to not just the
three of us would probably a lot of
other people in the room we are end of
Cold War post Cold War we are Goliath
like it or not and in the immortal words
of the great Los Angeles philosopher
Wilt Chamberlain no one roots for
Goliath but we we are very vulnerable to
charges of national immodesty we have
become a I think we are perceived as an
imperialist nation whether we are or not
I don't know but we are the damndest
crossbreed because we're an isolationist
imperialist nation if we are imperious
we are not really interested in the rest
of the world only in the most narrow way
if it affects us in some direct security
we don't listen to others don't seem to
care about others the great index of
this is my own profession the major
networks where a real star a real
trouper when I was a young man was to be
a foreign correspondent they don't have
foreign correspondents anymore it's gone
done they don't care about the rest of
the world and that immodesty about us
and other and the capacity to listen and
to know the limits of power the limits
of a culture I mean that we've written
and spoken a lot tonight about the
blessing but we're not the only nation
in the world that has
wonderful things we are not uniquely
wonderful there's a moment in I'm very
bothered by the the immodesty there's a
moment in april nineteen forty-five when
the british make dwight eisenhower in
the commander of this great allied force
and make him an honorary citizen of
london and he gives his speech at the
town hall and it's a great speech
because he wrote it himself and it's
extraordinarily modest it's you can get
it sometimes in collections his son has
come out with a book and it's in in the
last year and it's in them bibliography
it's always been one of my favorite see
it because we're saying i come from the
heart of america and he talks about as a
boy growing up in abilene that he never
thought he would see a city like london
let alone be made an honorary citizen
and then he talks with great modesty
about the sacrifices that the british
and others have made for two years
before we get into the war and how one
who is a politician or general should
never garland himself on a sacrifice
made by the bodies of much younger
minutes it's a glorious speech it's
America at its best you really read that
speech as they I like this country I
like Who it has sent overseas to
represent us there's a disturbing
immodesty now as if we know the answer
to everything and we don't have to
listen to others and if the French
oppose us on something they are
cheese-eating surrender monkeys that's
the phrase that rep riffles I mean I
mean I mean this is a country the French
lost hundreds of thousands of men
battles like eeprom they're done and
fought gallantly I think in the bad
cause in and Ossian and now Jamie
whatever else they're not cheese-eating
surrender monkeys they only and it's
always by the way most of this immodesty
comes from people who've never heard
shots fired in anger that they have a
belief that post Cold War we have
answers that I don't know that we do I
mean I thought we were a much more
attractive country than the Soviets I
never thought they were as strong as the
B team and the CIA reports was making
them out to be I mean I think you know
they could build missiles but nothing
else in the country worked and country's
strength is the sum of many things is
not its missile production its health
its ability to deliver things its
housing it's education for a junk it's a
cute little thing and there are things
in the way we are losing young people
that are in our report cards hardly
perfect on some very elemental society
things for a just society i mean the
measurement on us should not be the
measurement of us versions and so yes it
is always should be us versus us and
that's what we should be seeking in
there there's an immodest moment now I
think there are people who have read the
wrong lesson from the collapse of the
Soviet empire which was their collapse
more than it was our victory the book is
defining a nation clearly we are not
fully defined yet it is an evolutionary
process with this country as it has been
for over 200 years but the insights of
what has brought us thus far are
wonderful from the the various voices
familiar voices around the country and
three that you've heard tonight Amy Chua
Roger Wilkins and David Halberstam so
thank you all for joining us in thank
you sir
defining a nation is published by
National Geographic visit National
Geographic calm for more information